place maintenant notre chronique
économique rendez vous incontournable du
jeudi la question qu'on se pose ce soir
et si la prochaine crise financière
venait de chine déjà épicentre
historique du coc vide la deuxième
économie mondiale doit maintenant gérer
la déconfiture de son secteur immobilier
avec la chute des leurs grandes ce
promoteur en défaut de paiement qui
croule sous une montagne de dettes après
avoir vu beaucoup trop grand alors pékin
est il en mesure de limiter la casse
l'immobilier chinois peut-il entraîner
une nouvelle crise comparable à celle
des subprimes on en parle tout de suite
avec l'économiste jacques sapir seller
dit aux échos
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques merci d'être avec nous
même à distance alors que se passe-t-il
aujourd'hui dans l'immobilier en chine
eh bien c'est fini on est probablement
en présence des prémices d'une crise
financière majeure l'immobilier chinois
a donné naissance à des sociétés qui
sont devenus de véritables gérard et
parler des verts grande et bien sûr mais
il ya aussi d'autres comme fantasia ou
cynique ces sociétés sont aujourd'hui
extrêmement d'aidé elles sont
confrontées à la stabilisation voire à
la baisse des prix tant de la demande
que de leur secteur d'activité la
situation s'est donc dégradé depuis ces
derniers mois et il faut bien dire que
les mesures qui ont été prises par le
gouvernement chinois ont fait plus qu
aggraver cette situation
planté le décor qu'est ce qu'un et la
rendent alors eva granby a été créée en
1996 tout d'abord dans l'immobilier est
la vraie véritablement décoller à partir
des années 2000 quand le gouvernement
chinois a massivement soutenu le secteur
du logement le résultat était un
développement tout à fait astronomiques
la valeur de la société a été multiplié
par huit de 2009 à 2017 autrement dit un
taux de croissance de 30% par an
evergrande et a poursuivi une expansion
très agressive y compris dans des
entreprises qui sont très éloignées de
son secteur d'origine par exemple des
entreprises de véhicules électriques les
parcs à thèmes et bien d'autres secteurs
ainsi et vers grande et à dépenser
2 7 milliards de dollars entre 2019 et
2021 rien que dans le développement des
véhicules électriques alors ces
investissements comprennent aussi par
exemple le développement de l'eau chan
flower island une un projet de
construction d'îles artificielles dans
la mer de chine et vers grande et est
donc devenu aujourd'hui un conglomérat
géant même à l'échelle chinoise alors
pourquoi les problèmes financiers
actuels avec ce que vous décrivez
alors l'endettement des verts grande et
stéphanie et des normes sont passives
autrement dit l'argent qu'elle doit aux
banques aux fonds d'investissement aux
autres sociétés immobilières et à des
particuliers dans le cadre d'une
politique de préachat des logements et
bien cet endettement atteint
actuellement 310 milliards de dollars
grosso modo 275 milliards d'euros
autrement dit 12% du pib de la france
ces empreintes avaient dégagé sur le
portefeuille immobilier de l'entreprise
or depuis un an comme je les dis les
prix de l'immobilier ont cessé
d'augmenter certains ont même commencé à
baisser et donc la valeur immobilière du
capital qui sert de garantie à ses
empreintes se contracte les
investisseurs qui avaient prêté à river
grandet s'inquiète de plus il ya
maintenant des rumeurs de fraudes qui
circulent de manière insistante depuis
le mois d'octobre 2021 ces pratiques il
faut le dire ne se limite pas à evere
grandes elles sont courantes dans
plusieurs grandes sociétés immobilières
chinoises et on peut donc penser que et
20 grandes pourrait être un petit peu la
face émergée la partie émergée de
l'iceberg financiers en chine alors fait
que le gouvernement chinois est ce qu il
a pris la conscience quand même du
problème comme vous nous décrivez oui
naturellement naturellement et dans un
effort pour freiner l'endettement
excessif du secteur immobilier le
gouvernement chinois a adopté une
stratégie dite des trois lignes rouges
en 2020 pour justement limiter les
volumes dans près là ça veut dire que
les différentes sociétés doivent
respecter trois ratios un ratio entre
leurs niveaux de dette et les liquidités
immédiates qu'elles ont un ratio entre
les dettes et les fonds propres en
général un autre ratio entre les dettes
et les actifs
ces réglementations il faut bien le dire
ont fortement impacté evergrande --la
société a annoncé en mars 2021 qu'elle
cherchait à réduire son endettement de
23 milliards de dollars 23 milliards de
dollars par rapport à 310 milliards de
dollars on voit c'est pas énorme malgré
tout comme réduction mais au moins il
faut aussi rappeler qui est grande et
est toujours en expansion
l'année dernière elle avait lancé pas
moins de 63 projets dans le cours de
2020 théâtre alors d'autres
réglementations été prise que ce soit
par le gouvernement central ou par les
gouvernements locaux le résultat c'est
que en octobre 2021 quatorze des trente
plus grandes sociétés immobilières
chinoises se trouvait en infraction avec
au moins une des règles alors l'une
était en infraction avec les trois
règles que j'ai cité était grande et et
greenland holding en avait enfreint deux
et les 11 autres sociétés avaient eu en
fera au moins une de ces réglementations
et on se demande évidemment que peut
faire pétain quelle est la marge de
manoeuvre
oui effectivement alors en plus il ya le
problème des risques que vous comprenez
bien le risque il est tout d'abord
direct un certain nombre de banques de
fonds d'investissement américains ou
européens on prêtait déjà de l'argent
arrivé à grande et subir et évidemment
les conséquences d'une faillite de cette
société cependant le risque est aussi
peut-être même surtout un risque
indirect déjà des sociétés de taille
moyenne comme fantasia ou chimiques sont
en défaut de paiement mais avec
l'hypothétique faillite d'evergrande il
faudrait s'attendre à ce que de
nombreuses sociétés soit entraîné avec
elle car si le secteur de l'immobilier
s'effondre en chine et ce secteur il
faut toujours le rappeler représente
pratiquement 30% presqu'un tiers du pib
de la chine est bien la crise sera
profonde parce que ça touche aussi une
partie de l'industrie qui alimente ce
secteur est moins qu'ailleurs ces crises
ne fera pas que toucher la chine une
forte récession de l'économie chinoise
contaminera immédiatement les économies
occidentales celle des états unis
monsieur mais aussi celle de l'allemagne
qui exporte beaucoup par rapport à la
chine merci jacques sapir